hey here's an update about Florida
Republican Republican Attorney General
Pam Bondi background August of 2013 Pam
Bondi reached out to Donald Trump wanted
support from Trump for her 2014
re-election campaign in Florida the
following month in September of 2013
Bondi's office of the Attorney General
acknowledged they were investigating
Trump's now known to be incredibly
fraudulent Trump University just a few
days later Donald Trump's Charitable
Foundation which by the way is not even
allowed legally to donate to political
campaigns cut a check for 25 grand to a
group supporting Pam Bondi's re-election
campaign they ultimately ended up paying
a fine for that donation and then just
three weeks later
Pam Bondi's office of the Attorney
General lo and behold reverses course
and says we're actually not going to
pursue the fraud allegations against
Trump University in March of 2014
Trump offered Bondi's reelection
campaign a really good deal renting out
his mar-a-lago Resort in Florida and now
Florida Republican Attorney General Pam
Bondi has accepted a position with the
Trump administration on a presidential
commission it's the Commission on
combating drug addiction and the opioid
crisis and the weird thing about this is
that the Commission's work is almost
done they're actually supposed to be
issuing a report about their findings on
October 1st and just a few days ago Pam
Bondi has accepted the role really kind
of a weird thing because the role ends
in a few weeks but the real issue is
this is yet another example of how Trump
bragged on stage about knowing how to
work the system he knows how to use it
to his advantage he knows how to buy
politicians it was during one of the
Republican primary debates when they
went after him for giving money to
Hillary Clinton and he bragged I give
money to everybody I know how to get
things done in exchange for that money
Bondi dropped the investigation after he
donated the money it should have been a
massive scandal it would have killed
many other candidates but this is Trump
and this was relatively low on the list
of endless scandals he had and you
wonder why would a charitable
organization be donating to a group
affiliated with Pam Bondi's campaign it
just doesn't seem to square up but
apparently the Donald Trump people are
saying that it was an accident and that
$25,000 was meant to go to a Kansas
nonprofit oh you know how that sometimes
happens I I've accidentally donated
millions to the wrong nonprofit yeah no
I understand how it happens to the best
of us and in the background what's not
being mentioned is that the
investigation into Trump University
should have continued thousands of
people were scammed by Trump University
people lost their life savings moms
veterans you name it and Bondi is one of
many associate of political associates
including the Texas Attorney General
Greg Abbott who also gave Trump a slap
on the wrist and dropped a state
investigation into Trump University it
is sick and Pam Bondi later endorsed
Trump she said that they had been
friends for years
you can see them in this picture just
hanging out at some event I mean their
ties go back a long time
nice little political system we have
here it would be a shame if anything
happened to it for the people in power
that is discuss this with us on our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
sponsor is taga dab the hosting
specialist whatever your hosting needs
for your business or project taga dab
can do it dedicated servers virtual
private servers cloud server solutions
colocation custom server solutions and
the big thing at taga dab is there
customer support over 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
this is a testament to the great support
that they give their customers currently
rated a nine point seven out of 10
according to the Trustpilot
review system with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud tag
a DAB currently offers our viewers and
listeners a twenty british pound free
credit about twenty four US dollars to
all new customers that sign up gives you
a chance to try the service this is a
limited availability offer for the
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to signup tag a DAB
comm /td PS and
use the offer code TDPS 20 during
account registration support our
sponsors and support our show in doing
so sign up ta ga da be calm /t DPS
coupon code is T DPS 20